[Music]
The Fallout games are simply iconic
since the 90s the games have been
thrilling players with their crazy world
and fascinating atmosphere after the
huge hit the last of us we can now look
forward to the next eagerly awaited
series adaptation of a game classic in
this video you can find out everything
you need to know about the Fallout
series which will soon be released on
Amazon Prime
video The Fallout video games tell the
story of a post-apocalyptic world that
was destroyed by a nuclear war in the
year 2077 players explore the
radioactively contaminated Earth and
have to deal with the likes of mutants
scavengers and weird Cults in addition
to a good amount of humor the style of
the American 50s is a particular
characteristic of the series from
petticoats and Cadillacs to transistor
radios the world looks as though time
has stood still since the catastrophe at
the same time Fallout also contains
typical science fiction elements from
this period for example in the form of
talking robots and laser weapons the
ruins and artifacts of the past are
characterized by the once hopeful view
of a bright future with the power of of
the atom combine all this with a touch
of Mad Max and the peculiar charm of
Fallout is
complete it is already known that the
series will not pick up on a specific
story from the games but will tell its
own story the first hints of the plot of
The Fallout series were given in a
teaser trailer which was presented at
this year's gamescon in Germany as the
video has not been shown to the general
public yet we have to rely on the
accounts of eyewitnesses the video is
said to show footage of the so-called
Brotherhood of Steel they are a strongly
militaristic community that is
especially striking for its equipment
for example in the form of huge power
armor a firefight in which the
Brotherhood is involved follows
afterwards a woman is seen leaving her
Vault for the first time and discovering
the post-apocalyptic World vaults are
the many bunkers in which people sought
Shelter From the third world war in the
games it is frequently the case that the
inhabitants only leave these vaults
centuries later and then meet other
people who have already settled in the
new world the isolated bunkers are also
often used to conduct crazy social
experiments surely a good opportunity
for mystery and horror elements in the
series Amazon Prime also posted an
artwork on the social media platform X
which shows us the well-known Vault boy
against the backdrop of Los Angeles The
Vault boy is wearing the typical blue
suit of the Vault inhabitants a 33 can
be seen on its chest this suggests that
the action will take place in and around
La and that Vault 33 will be of
relevance during filming said photos
were regularly leaked showing for
instance a warehouse including the vault
tech logo and various photos of a vault
32 it therefore seems that there will be
several bunkers in the
series one of the better actors in The
Fallout cast is undoubtedly Walton Goins
who appeared as the villain in Tomb
Raider and Quinton Tarantino's the
hateful eight for example the first
rumors suggest that goggin could play a
ghoul a ghoul is a type of mutated human
who is exposed to high levels of
radiation for an extended period of time
during the Great War another leading
role is played by Ella Pernell known for
the acclaimed series Yellow Jackets Twin
Peaks Legend Kyle mcglaughlin will also
make an appearance in several episodes
other roles include Moises Aras as Norm
Johnny pton as thadius and Aaron Moten
as Max Maximus the character named
Maximus is strongly reminiscent of
Caesar's Legion a Roman inspired faction
from the game Fallout New Vegas which is
located at least close to the series
plot many fans would certainly be happy
to meet these Fanatics
again Amazon is producing the upcoming
Fallout Series in collaboration with
kilter films Bethesda game studios and
Bethesda softworks meaning the creators
of the popular games had some say in the
project as announced in 2020 the scripts
were written by Christopher Nolan's
brother Jonathan and his wife Lisa Joy
Jonathan Nolan has already written
screenplays for hits such as
Interstellar and Westworld the pair also
directed the First episodes of the
series since the series has already been
shot there's presumably nothing to stop
it from being released as planned The
Fallout series will premiere on Amazon
Prime video on April 12th 2024 we can't
wait to find out whether we were in for
a similar level of success as The Last
of Us the Legendary game series
definitely deserves it as do its
fans
[Music]